what's going on reject nation we got
ourselves our first official trailer for
miss marvel about a muslim pakistani
american kamala khan getting some more
of that representation in the mcu but
before that let's welcome back our
favorite white
i
boy
like john i cannot talk about this
person i don't care if you're recovering
from surgery you get over here we gotta
talk about miss marvel your favorite
marvel character right man
really relates to my experiences in life
you know i'm excited leave a like for
john
and let's see what's going on with this
trailer too while we're at it
[Music]
that's kind of cool actually
okay so first off i just want to say
i get it
you get what
high school
[Music]
scott pilgrim vibes yeah definitely
[Music]
[Music]
maybe they're right
i spent too much time
being a muslim fantasy land
it's all gonna pay off
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city
you saved the world
[Music]
what does it feel like
[Music]
i always thought i wanted this kind of
life
but i never imagined any of this
you know
[Music]
oh they like straight up change her
powers yeah
it's right out of the comic book cover
there ah it's like right on the copper
cover that looks lovely
it does look delightful yeah it's
interesting that's really interesting i
mean i really like the aesthetic choice
that they had especially at the top
because as representing the trailer as
someone who's obsessed with superheroes
so i like when you you know you're doing
the thought bubbles that go into the
marvel logo it feels very much like
scott pilgrim versus the world mixed
with shazam the best way i probably
describe the vibe that this game us also
with that what was that haley steinfeld
movie with woody harrelson 17 i think
it's called seven teams something like
that yeah especially the relationship
that she was having with uh looks like a
counselor yeah yeah a cool guidance
counselor cool guidance counselor yeah
but in the in the comics she gets hit
with like territories the thing that
essentially creates in humans and she
has like the embigging abilities here
this looks to be more lining up with
this cosmic captain marvel types of
powers yeah in fact
she had like those like chongqi looking
kind of quantum rings
activated in something and she even says
directly like the powers she feels
cosmic or something like that yeah i
imagine that they're changing her
abilities and i heard rumors that they
might change her abilities because
obviously we have fantastic four coming
into the picture now so you'll have mr
fantastic in the mcu so the powers would
be too much correlated so they wanted to
mix it up but they have more going for
it than just the power set and uh yeah
it looks like a cute teen comedy well
yeah absolutely and i wonder if they'll
take a chance to maybe do a pivot and
and relate her character to other sides
of the mcu i mean obviously they're
going to take her more cosmic but
there's also that ant-man doodle in her
book and there is you know something to
at least iterations of the character
where she shares like
molecular dna like you know deep down
cellular connections with herself across
multiverses and across time and space so
i'm sure they could also do a bunch with
that but yeah it made me wonder like
what's the nature of this gauntlet is
there some kind of cosmic curse on it is
there terrigen crystals inside of it or
something like that either way i mean i
love just the tone and the spirit that
it seems to be evoking and yeah like you
mentioned scott pilgrim you know the
very sort of stylized comic book kind of
look but also you know going further
down that rabbit hole of borrowing from
you know teen and high school movies and
stuff like that and the coming of age
stories like on it looks very fun and
relatable in a way that doesn't feel
like
you know you're you're stereotypical
like oh we're trying to get woke like i
bet there's millions who disagree with
you no i can't imagine it you know but
hey feel free to show me but yeah you
know i mean i love that she does even
just as of this minute and a half clip
here feel like a tangible real relatable
person who also has a background and
experience that's very different from
you know what i'm familiar with yeah i
think the show will probably lean into
that i don't imagine like disney is i
watch the movie like cheaper by the
dozen the other day which actually
surprised me they're like oh they're
they are leaning into the race element
here i imagine that they will lean into
that too because like you have the
conversation in here of like what's my
place in this world where do i belong i
don't know what it's like to be a muslim
pakistani teenager but i imagine that
they would deal with what that must feel
like as a teen living in new jersey
what your position in the world is by
the way speaking of new jersey man like
so much goes on over there an nj in the
mcu
they don't get enough credit it's always
about new york city but you know what we
got like west view captain america when
her soldier took place there i feel like
there's another thing that's missing
those are the two that came to mind when
i was watching this and i really feel
like that camaraderie relationship that
she's having with her friend where she's
like showing her power sets does remind
me a lot of what they do in shazam as
well i don't know who the bad guy is i
don't really know what's gonna imagine
captain marvel might make an appearance
in this show we'll see but this seems to
be capturing this is supposed to be the
audience cipher for what it feels like
for kids who probably admire the marvel
cinematic universe as well
um but yeah she looks great she looks
charming this looks fun but as far as
like what i'm looking forward to most
out of the mcu i don't look like i'm the
target demographic for it i mean it
looks adorable
so it's not really a criticism not like
oh my god i'm dying to watch this right
now because it feels like more like a
cute teen show however i i do like those
who i mentioned your brother does and i
was like you know what i like this
cheesy crap
i feel like that's the same way i'm
gonna restaurant it's like this looks
like just a good family time we're
probably gonna have a lot of heart and a
lot of good messages yeah i'm a
sensitive fellow sometimes i'm a sucker
for for those kinds of things anyway
guys what you think about the miss
marvel trailer is it better than what
you imagine the thor love and thunder
trailer will look like leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to get
accepted into the reject nation click
that like button last but not least
adelia chamberlain you to me are the ms
marvel of this channel i would love to
see making a lot of other women at the
patreon jealous but please continue i
mean you are one of a few because it's
the multiverse variants but today
you are the marvels you're you're
captain marvel you're miss marvel you're
maria ram but you're photon you're
everybody adelia you're the locust
person here because you're from
everywhere you're every ethnicity you
are every she's probably the white of
smarts
hey what's white if not the absence of
color with which we can fill the blank
canvas to the you know uh heart's
content and adelia i mean you are
somebody who has a big imagination just
waiting to be let out to the world
begging for that one last push of
colorful brightness to get your message
out there to get your spirit and your
wonderful qualities to the world
you
are the most ethnic person i know so hey
keep it really love you very much
and we'll uh we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you